they give you on this is square next
okay so you can see graph goes across
and they're going to create a particular
area and they go into you or take that
alright so I think they want ya they end
up in this one's gonna be a little more
complicated than the simpler example
today to show you this area it goes off
forever so you introduce a new boundary
and now I've got a finite area just like
I had to find an area they had I have
upper lower balance Dan got this and you
can see what happens right let me just
rewind because that was the creek who
split yeah let's go in quarter one
alright
sorry just look again carefully they
take this and to rotate it around about
I really all right so now we going into
another plane
yeah that's frame rate guys okay and you
can see as it comes around you can
picture the potter's wheel right that's
what gives you the shape now notice
unlike mine this shape has a hole in the
middle
why is it a hole in the yeah very good
if you come back if you come back to
here alright you see the hole in the
middle comes from this spot here right
that's if you like that's air that's
also being rotated around the axis just
like this solid line is so when you
rotate that around you get that Hollett
hot so once you've got that that's what
gives you a solid and that's what's
being considered so what we're doing
with our drawing and shading i kind of
be is to try and approximate
you can see you can see what he's doing
right he's slicing it just like I did
and that's that cylindrical slice just
like we had before now this would have a
hole in the middle just like I cut it
out
but I would work it out in exactly the
same way because I'm gonna talk about
this a bit later on when you can sit on
this one big shape all right I can
consider that as one big shot and then I
can take this soul in it and just
subtract it just like we were doing the
areas between curves right you're like
this integral is a one area so you
subtract another integral which is
another area this one you're gonna have
a big interview which is the beetball
you and that wheel into really there
which is a small amount of oil you're
gonna subtract them and we will look at
those cases tomorrow morning now let me
just give a caution a lot of people
where's my other color my danger
agreement a lot of people who write this
formula like sir they will say volume
equals and they'll notice at the pie the
pie is just a constant right so they'll
throw the pie out the front like so now
mathematically there's nothing wrong
with it obviously in fact I encourage
you as much as possible when you see
constants in there generally take it out
because it's just one less thing to
worry about okay
however I'm going to strongly discourage
you from writing like this and there's a
reason why I put a big red ball truck
it's two reasons number one when you
write it like this it's really really
painfully obvious where the numbers
where the pretty rules came from it's a
cylinder you're adding a bunch of
cylinders that are all infinitesimally
thin okay
so it's like there's my PI R squared H
it's very obvious right whereas here
it's like the PI just kind of comes out
the front it's like waited what what is
this what is this and the answer is well
it's 2/3 of the formula for the volume
of the cylinder right why don't the
whole thing there the second reason is
when people write it like this half the
time and if we get the pie okay because
it's so easy to forget the pie you're
focusing on the integral you're focusing
on getting this thing right and then
integrating la da da da and you wouldn't
believe the number
times people forget the pie if the pie
is in the integral and you remember it
is PI R squared H you'll remember it
much better okay so let's do a concrete
example shall we I'm draw up a new set
of axes and put just up with exactly
what y equals x squared
okay so I'm not gonna write it out
because it'll take me a bit of time just
to put it on the board but the typical
way you will see a question like this
one is find the volume when the area
underneath y equals x squared that be
not shaded in there
find the volume when that area is
rotated around and then they'll name an
axis for you now just as we're starting
out I'm just gonna leave it on the
x-axis just like we did before we'll
talk about what happens when you want to
rotate it in different ways but baby
steps okay what is the volume when the
area underneath wife is x squared
between 1 & 2 is rotated around the
x-axis okay and so that area of the
shaded for you now tip for beginners in
order to make your ball you look a bit
reasonable okay remember that this shape
ought to be symmetrical about whichever
axis you rotate okay so if you join your
y equals x squared there I would advise
you to get your ruler okay and you can
see where I put my two men I don't know
where your 2 is right but just measure
up to where the 2 hits the y intercepts
thank the y coordinate lot up okay
whatever that length is so on my board
is on my board because I have a
ridiculous
it looks like 15 centimeters I don't
expect their background to be that large
okay but whatever it ends up being that
distance make sure you're roughly the
same down here unless you end up with a
lopsided ridiculous-looking volume okay
once you've got that that's kind of the
most important point you would do the
same thing for your lower bound but he
because we're on the axis the reflection
is itself okay that's where I'm going to
go and then you draw your dis kind of
thing at the bottom yeah yeah sure what
can I say yeah the wedding love is not
that important and you'll encounter a
whole bunch so I'm going to rotate it
around like
I think it's good practice to put that
bit in the back make it kind of dotted
like that because your diagram is gonna
get pretty busy and then you just need
to reflect that shape you have at the
top down to the bottom and there is your
shape okay if you like if you want to
make every mortgage you can put some
light round lines there to indicate it's
ramping okay seriously I'm making sure
that we communicate clearly through your
diagram what would the shape is you're
doing very old okay so there's the
volume right I'm going to form my
equation right
and here's tends to be the way that I do
it I think about my formula I know what
my boundaries are right it's zero to two
and then I put in here's my volume of a
cylinder right so it's PI now what is
wine in this case I actually have a
value for one it's X square so I got x
squared squared DX okay so there's my PI
R squared H right there's my cylinder
yes correct
when when we have a look there are other
ways to find volume use that in
extension to you will learn about and
then you have to be you have to go back
a little more but this is actually a
Chino result you can go straight there
if you want you can write this line down
but this line is kind of like it's kinda
like Pythagoras a squared plus B squared
C squared no one's going to give you any
marks speaking to me that they will they
will avoid understanding for using the
formula problem okay all right so that's
that this is the point where having
written down the play now I know it's
there now I take it out the front so I'm
going to stick that pi there from north
to 2 of X to the 4 and then this is just
an integral it's just an integral right
so what's my primitive X to the 5 on 5
I'm gonna evaluate it from north to -
you can't really see what's going on
here right so this is 32 on 5 tape 0 and
my number and just to be nice and neat
and tied up over there for my volume is
and this is where I'm going to stick my
unit on and of course they're cubic
units because it's evolving okay this is
not complicated at all it's just a
natural extension out of I can have
these things I can out of those out of
these what else can I add up right
integration serves this purpose for
everything okay